welcome back the top stories on sky
world news islamic state says it carried
out Monday's suicide bomb attack in
Turkey which killed 31 young peace
activists in Burundi voters have gone to
the polls amid unrest over president
Pierre and currencies s decision to
stand for a third consecutive term in
office and Donald Trump is under growing
pressure to pull out of the race for the
White House over controversial comments
he made about fellow Republican John
McCain the Islamic state terror group
has claimed responsibility for that
suicide bomb attack in turkeys Kurdish
town of storage many say that with the
extremists fighting Syrian Kurds across
the border it was just a matter of time
before turkeys Kurds were also targeted
we spoke to the journalist Dorian Jones
who's in Istanbul there is a feeling of
shock all across the nation because many
of those that were killed were not only
Kurds but Turks and and very young I
mean these were you mainly University
students those that have killed were all
across the country from the Black Sea
from Istanbul all across the country
were victims of this terrible bombing so
the feeling of shock goes far beyond
just occurred but across the whole
country but it has to be said while
there is a great deal of shock that
isn't that much surprised because
critics of the government for some time
have been warning its policy they claim
of ignoring Islamic state threat leaves
turkey open to such an attack and this
attack does seem to vindicate those
fears in the last few weeks Turkey has
been turning its attention to the
Islamic state there's been a few dozen
arrests across the country and by raised
by the police against Islamic state
supporters people linked to the
smuggling of people across Turkey into
Syria sympathizers and on top of that
the Turkish military have been stepping
up their operations or preventing people
crossing into Syria along its
longboarders that we have seen hundreds
of people in the last few weeks being
stopped by the security forces now the
people who have suggested that the
Islamic state are now clearly upset by
this and this bombing could well be a
warning and a retaliation
such government is under an enormous
amount of pressure to to act to bring
those responsible for these bombings and
what is more to prevent any repeat of
these bombings there is a great deal of
fear that this could be just the first
in a wave of attacks by the Islamic
state analysts do warned though that
either he does ratchet up its operations
against the Islamic state then that
could provoke further attacks but at the
moment the government is under huge
pressure to to be seen to be taking a
far more stringent attitude towards the
Islamic state and the Prime Minister
Ahmet Davutoglu has said that all
efforts will be made to crack down on
these people to bring them to justice
the Turkish security forces across the
country on high alert all leave is being
cancelled so it does appear at least in
rhetoric and initial actions that they
do appear to be prepared to step up the
battle against the Islamic state